the centers for disease control data
showing nevada is on the rise compared
to other states when it comes to
vaccines
administered per capita not too long ago
we were near last today we're number 35
in front of larger states like
maryland georgia and illinois 8 news now
reporter sally jaramillo live near the
strip with more
on that positivity rate steadily going
down good to see that sally
brian each day the positivity rate is
going down we are now at 9.6 percent
less than 10 percent and just to give
you some perspective
we do want to let you know that those
that rate actually we hadn't seen that
since last november for the beginning of
november hospitalization rates have also
decreased now during today's meeting
with the state's kova 19 response team
the discussion was about the cases going
down director caleb cage says
the decline is not directly related to
the testing as other states
are also seeing numbers decline when
there is a decline in cases there is
also a decline in demand for testing
the state is trying to determine how
much of the testing decline is made up
with rapid tests
there are a number of
non-psr type tests like the binax now
and other tests that are a part
of the overall testing infrastructure in
the state of nevada
but that are not required to be reported
through the pcr testing system
ashley fostage epidemiologist with the
office of public health investigations
was also on the call
she says notification of covenant test
results will now be released faster
this will be done through a notification
system that uses
text message reporting live near the
strip sally caramillo 8 news now